hemos hablado mucho sobre espejos en
particular sobre espejos parabólicos que
reflejan la luz pero en esta ocasión
quiero hablarles sobre lentes y pensar
en cómo es que éstos transmiten o
refractan la luz y en particular nos
vamos a enfocar en lentes convexos
lentes convexos
recuerden que cóncavo es como si
acabaran un hueco es decir que tendría
una abertura hacia adentro mientras que
convexo tendrá la abertura hacia afuera
estará abultado y un ente convexo será
simétrico vamos a dibujar
ponemos bien estado vamos a dibujar un
más o menos una cara del lente convexo
así iba a ser simétrico entonces va a
tener
esta parte en el centro y de este otro
lado vamos a tener otra superficie igual
bueno igual aunque mi dibujo no es el
mejor del mundo pero hay
esa es la idea vemos que no suceda a la
luz conforme pasa a través de excelente
si es transmitida o si es disfrutada
asumimos que este lente está hecho de
vidrio o de algún material con un alto
índice de refracción en el cual la luz
va a viajar mucho más lentamente
imaginemos un rayo de luz que va así
paralelo al eje principal que de hecho
lo voy a dibujar el eje principal de
este lente va a estar en esta posición
y se va a extender hasta acá
entonces tenemos nuestro rayo de luz que
toca al lente aprovecho aquí para
dibujar la perpendicular a este punto de
la superficie del lente y recordemos que
la luz se va a mover mucho más rápido
aquí afuera que aquí en el lente por lo
que el lado derecho del rayo va a estar
afuera un poco más y si recordamos la
analogía del automóvil nos daremos
cuenta que la parte de arriba irá más
rápido que la parte de abajo del rayo al
momento de pasar a este material del
lente
recordemos esta analogía nos
imaginábamos que aquí hay un auto aquí
están sus ruedas va viajando en este
sentido del rayo al llegar a este medio
más lento
las primeras llantas que van a entrar al
medio lento van a ser las de este lado
por los que van a empezar a ir despacio
y las llantas de aquí arriba o de la
derecha del rayo van a seguir con
velocidad por lo que este rayo
girar un poco hacia este sentido así que
el rayo va a ser disfrazado hacia abajo
ahora el rayo de luz va a pasar de un
medio lento a un medio más rápido
entonces el lado izquierdo del rayo va a
alcanzar al medio más rápido primero por
lo que va a girar así y va a continuar
hasta este punto ahora hay un punto por
aquí afuera en el que cualquier rayo que
llegue de forma paralela a este lente se
va a retractar de la misma manera
convergiendo en el mismo punto y creo
que ustedes ya se imaginan cómo voy a
llamar a este punto así que si yo tengo
cualquier rayo que llegue de forma
paralela a este eje principal
baa
disfrutarse así nuevamente aquí y va a
llegar a este punto lo mismo si llega un
rayo paralelo por acá va a
cambiará así y luego va a retractarse lo
escribo mejor que mi pulso no es el
mejor ahorita de manera que va a llegar
a este mismo punto el punto donde todos
estos rayos y quizás ustedes ya hayan
escuchado el término de rayos colima 2
que se refiere a los rayos que son más o
menos paralelos al eje principal se van
a unir aquí al ser refractados por el
lente y en este punto donde se
concentran se le llama foco del lente
del ente también pueden ver la distancia
entre este punto y el lente como la
distancia focal
excelente es completamente simétrico
todo lo que llega de un lado se enfocará
del otro si tuviéramos rayos colima 2
que llegan ahora de este lado y son
paralelos al eje se entra el ente cambia
aquí luego vuelve a cambiar de manera
que van a convertir en este punto por lo
que aquí en este otro lado adelante
también va a haber un foco por lo que
por cada lente vamos a tener dos focos
una cosa que vamos a asumir cuando
trabajemos con lentes para simplificar
es asumir un lente esbelto o delgado hay
una diferencia entre la distancia que
hay dentro de este lente aquí hay una
distancia que va a ser diferente a la
distancia que se encuentra acá pero
nuestros vídeos de conceptos básicos
vamos a ignorar esta diferencia de
distancia en el lente y vamos a asumir
que el lente es delgado
usando esto vamos a imaginar qué es lo
que sucede con la luz en los siguientes
ejemplos no me preocuparé por este caso
de refracción intermedia voy a hacer un
poco de espacio acá para dibujar algunos
ejemplos
vamos a dibujar un lente sencillo
que es delgado y
es simétrico
tiene dos puntos focales uno en este
lado
efe y otro en este otro lado
veamos lo que este lente hará con las
imágenes de diversos objetos dibujemos
el eje principal en el que ambos puntos
focales se van a encontrar
y vamos a poner un objeto alejado de un
punto focal vamos a dibujar nuestro
objeto con la convención de la flecha
este es nuestro objeto que va a pasar
recordemos que podemos tomar cualquier
punto del objeto y que este va a
reflejar la luz de manera difusa vamos a
elegir puntos en donde podamos predecir
qué es lo que va a pasar con la luz
vamos a tomar un punto aquí en este
extremo del objeto y vamos a elegir un
rayo de luz que sale paralelo al eje
principal para llegar a lente y aquí se
va a disfrazar de manera que va a pasar
por el punto focal del otro lado
ahora si tomo otro punto de luz que sale
de este mismo lugar pero pasa por el
punto focal más cercano cuando llegue al
lente va a ser refractados de manera
paralela al eje así que estos se van a
unir aquí espero que esto tenga sentido
porque aquí tenemos una situación
simétrica algo que llegue en paralelo
del lado izquierdo va a salir del lente
y va a pasar hacia el punto focal que se
encuentra a la derecha y algo que pase
por el punto focal de la izquierda al
llegar a la lente va a ser retractado de
forma paralela hacia el lado derecho
todo lo que pase por este lente
proveniendo del objeto va a convertir en
este punto de acá en este punto de acá
los rayos que salen de la base del
objeto van a pasar por el lente vamos a
dibujarlo aquí con este color van a
pasar por acá los rayos van a atravesar
el lente y van a pasar por el punto
focal y se va a extender hasta acá por
lo que vamos a tener una imagen del
objeto invertida
así así que en este ejemplo parece que
tenemos una imagen escribimos imagen
porque se puede proyectar
invertida
tira
es una imagen real como les decía porque
la luz de hecho está convergiendo en
esta parte y esta imagen se puede
proyectar y difundir la luz de la misma
manera que lo es el objeto original en
el siguiente vídeo seguiremos
practicando con diagramas de este tipo
para saber qué tipo de imágenes
obtendremos dependiendo de la ubicación
del objeto sobre el eje principal en el
punto focal más lejano o más cercano
etcétera en fin practicaremos mucho
sobre cómo la luz es refractiva